steps leader of the SMP Maria black
thank you Mr Speaker I would also like
to begin by thanking all of the staff
and our health services across these
Isles and as we celebrate the 75th
anniversary of the health services in
the UK I want to reflect on two quotes
from two people the first one is it's
something it's about using the private
sector more something we should be very
comfortable with the second quote is
people go as NHS patients to the private
sector and we could do more of it can I
ask the Deputy Prime Minister which
quote is from the PM and which is from
the leader of the opposition
well Mr Speaker may I actually just
Begin by saying genuinely how sorry I
was to hear that the honorable lady will
be standing down at the next election
she and I joined this house at the same
time and I know she has contributed much
to her party and to this place and may I
also say I'm sure she will wish to join
me in celebrating his majesty King
Charles receiving the Scottish regalia I
pretty much as we speak
[Applause]
[Music]
for Damascus conversion Mr Speaker but
when when it comes to the NHS I would
take absolutely no lectures from either
party on it it has been there for me I
was born in an NHS hospital my children
were born in the NHS hospital it's been
there for me and my family and this
government has put record funding into
it
in this place at the same time and I'm
pretty sure we'll be leaving at the same
time
[Applause]
the number one problem that faces the
health service across these Isles is
Workforce and research shows that brexit
has worsened the UK's shortage of
doctors European nurses registering to
work in the UK fell by 90 after the
brexit referendum what more will it take
for both him and the labor party to
admit the damage that brexit is causing
our health services
let me prime minister well it all
started off so nicely Mr Speaker but um
I don't know whether the old lady has
actually been
you know
2.4 billion pounds for our
groundbreaking NHS Workforce plan that
is the first time in the nhs's history
that that has happened and if you look
at the record since this party came to
power almost 40 000 more doctors and
more than 50 000 more nurses once again
the conservative party delivering for
the NHS celebrity